Pete Holmes is on the podcast today and
I gotta say I I loved talking to Pete
Holmes wow talk about his special we
talk about God lack thereof you decide
uh before we get to Pete Holmes real
quick a little housekeeping June 28th
I'm going to be in Eerie Pennsylvania at
the Warner Theater July 6th 2024 I am
going to be at the Mirage in Las Vegas
this is all new material guys July 17th
2024 I'll be in Edmonton Alberta Canada
at The Great Outdoors Comedy Festival
with the Great Outdoor
see B Cher I also have a new special out
it's on
of.tv um very easy to get to Don't Panic
don't freak out just put in your browser
of.tv SL is it a slash or a dash we
always fight about this forward SL
Whitney that's just my name you'll go
right to it it's free you're not going
to see any nudity I don't know if that's
good news or bad news but the TV side is
completely different from the only fan
side enjoy it and now enjoy the great
Pete
Holmes I've done this podcast for a
little while yeah you haven't been on it
yet no I'm gonna just I'm mad I'm on it
and I'm I'm gonna say something yes that
we can cut out if you want sure I'm so
excited I already ran it by Pat Pat
loved it I'm not gonna take his advice
Pat said don't say it yeah
okay I one of my
biggest like
regrets no I have had this thing in my
head for a really long time that that
you I don't think you like me oh what is
this WTF
no no I'm so sorry oh that's my
nightmare to be confrontational are we
good it's really oh no I don't feel
confrontational but isn't that a lot of
Mark's episodes they're like air airing
it out yeah totally and that's not what
I'm trying to do and I think something
that with you you and I both had I I
don't want to insult you by saying we've
had a similar career but we both like
had shows with our name on it and we
both like did talk shows and I think
I've always been kind of embarrassed
around you embarrassment being one of my
probably my biggest thing right a quote
I love about comedy is we become
comedians to control how we're
embarrassed oh you know yeah because I
think that you're one person I can't
hide from like you know when you have a
TV show and people are like oh like I
can't hide how bad I wanted it I can't
hide how hard I tried I can't hide cuz
there's another gargoyle next to you
well
you bring me the skulls of every failed
pilot
Creator like you uniquely know how much
work it takes to get what we both got
how bad you have to want it how hard it
is to lose it yeah that is embarrassing
like there's very few people that I can
really say I mean Seinfeld had a
different situ like we've other people
have had shows but we kind of were like
not trying to do the same thing at the
same time I'm not saying this perfectly
interesting uh you've always been
inspiring to me I've always kind
of get the get the fuck get get I always
saw you as someone that I could never be
like oh no I'm just it's like I'm not
trying that hard I'm kind of like you're
one of the few people that I'm like oh
he knows he can see he knows that I have
pikme energy he knows that I'm a try
Hardy he knows he knows that I'm getting
a note
to be more likable and I'm taking it he
knows I'm changing the joke for the
executive like he knows yeah no I
understand that but it's that's
completely unfounded I drew a cartoon
for the New York no I mean I'm telling
you you have nothing to feel weird about
and I'm not I'll find something else
then yeah yeah yeah yeah I I believe it
never underestimate our brain's ability
that's really surprising to me I
wouldn't I never would have thought of
us on the same I I I think of you as
well ahead of me yeah that's interesting
like
old like near the grave like musty like
Dusty yeah look there so I just called
you old in my trying to go I put you on
a pedestal by trying to give you a huge
compliment I just called and then I
called you old which is terrible we're
really just killing each other no but I
just thought of you ahead of me I mean
when I saw that you made a show bro took
Broke Girls and like produced it I was
like oh that was very interesting to me
and inspiring to me I was like I didn't
even consider that we could do that that
seemed really cool to me and I had
friends on that show and I'd be like is
Whitney in the room and they were like
they said you were but it didn't seem
like you were you had to be there every
single day and well I couldn't because I
was doing the other one simultaneously
but I think you were doing a talk show
and another show simultaneously I think
no or something I don't think I ever did
anything simultaneously not like you did
but I thought that was really cool so
you've always just been an inspiring
figure to me and I don't have that I
don't look at you with disgust which is
what I'm hearing the fear is if we can
name it I think I just have always
thought where as it as an a blind
ambition monster for I think I've always
thought you're so cool and you're and it
you just it you talked about this on I
think Neils or on um maybe Rich rolls is
it Richard Roars that we're all screens
and we project onto each other I mean
pretty much any spiritual person would
probably say that yeah yeah and I think
that maybe I've projected on to you a
little bit because I've always just been
a fan and I just think you're so cool
and I've always wanted to be your friend
in a way that's a little try hard when
you did my talk show I remember being
quite Star Struck that you were there
and touched that you did it because it
was a little I'm not saying this
disparagingly but like so few people
were watching it when we were at the
rehearsals they'd normally be an
executive sleeping in the back row
literally sleeping and in the pilot the
first episode of my talk show I said
fuck and they didn't bleep it this is
how few people even the sensors weren't
watching it and then sometimes like no
one viewed
it I said fuck and it just went out
that's a that's a lack of viewership
internally when I was so my first
writing job was on last called the
Carson daily and I would do these like
correspondent pieces and the whatever
the bit I had pitched to do we needed to
play Thriller by Michael Jackson and it
was before I knew like you can't just
play Thriller and they're like oh this
would be like and I was like in the
producer was like let's just put it in
and you did we played it and it was fine
no one noticed yeah that's Carson that's
Pete home show Carson Dy stuff right
there not that we weren't even I'm not
putting down cards I'm just saying we
weren't even that big we were a small
show and that was I I think think back
on it so fondly but the people that came
through to do it and you were being one
of them was really meaningful to me like
gosh Kum was the first guest he was the
first guest on my podcast as well this
is before kumel got so big in both
ways in both ways literally in physic I
do think back then though correct me if
I'm wrong there felt like a little more
of a bifurcation in like alt comedy and
mainstream comedy and I think I maybe
thought you could so easily go back and
forth yeah and I I felt like I struggled
with going back and forth that's
interesting but that's just because of
when I started you're going to agree
with me that I've been wronged somehow
by your coolness I I'm not being falsely
humble when I think about myself I don't
typically think the word cool and that
that's not my Persona yeah I'm not being
like I'm just like I have similar
feelings where I look at other people
and I'm like wow that's so cool that's
like Rolling Stone like I'd never be on
Rolling Stone you know what I mean like
cool that I don't we all have different
benchmarks for what cool is to me I
think cool is like original like an
original thinker maybe you know not
derivative of anyone like I would always
watch your stand up and I wouldn't be
like oh he's doing a tow or he's doing
jalo or he's you know what I mean it was
always like this is just an
original you know it's an interesting
time that I what what I started to say
was when I was coming up and stand up
there was there were the the dwarves and
The Elves and the dwarves were like the
club Comics they were
like a in their beards eating ham and
then the elves were the alt people they
were gentler but also a little bit
faster on their feet and and weird yeah
and and but I came in the scene well
that boundary was sort of dissolving
places started closing in New York so
you couldn't go up at rafii anymore so
you had to go into the clubs and then
you started seeing people like Bill Burr
who's who's a a great hero of mine he
would come into the Boston and he would
go to an ALT room and do the same act
and I started being like oh this is
where it's at I used to have a set list
where my regular Club bits bits that
would work anywhere either place would
be written in regular and then the bits
that would only work in alt places would
be written in italics and I would look
at my set lus and be like I can't do
that here and I was right meaning it's
like what I was saying about the God bid
and the uh nothing makes any sense but
the fucking the stool was for the clubs
yeah yeah maybe for sure and the stool
is made of Adams is for the alt rooms
yeah exactly I'm fucking Adams right now
but like what it is is I I have such a a
heart for Comedians and for jokes and
what kills me is when you see people
doing good
jokes in the wrong place it doesn't mean
they're dumb it's just like I remember
Big Jay said that to me we were watching
some we're at the Boston a club in the
West Village of Manhattan very confusing
and Jay's there looking like somebody
covered him in Honey and rolled him
through a hot
Topp I love Jay but he's there he was
wearing fingerless gles gloves and he
got the Renaissance Fair yeah and and
he's sitting there and Jay would like
that I but he go we're watching somebody
eat shit doing a very very old set that
I knew was good he he probably knew it
was good but she was eating shit and he
just went know your audience and I was
like he's right but then and I remember
bombing in Germantown Wisconsin opening
for Jim Gaffin I was very lucky to open
for Jim and Bill in my first three years
stand it was huge my friend Dan Kaufman
got me those gigs shout out to Dan great
guy and anyway we both ate shit and the
MC who will remain nameless but I
remember his name very Road name I wish
I could say it it doesn't matter it
might as well be like woodpecker hell I
was going to say like worm McGill
something even the name was funny yeah
yeah yeah Beetle he did great and then I
went up no no no I was hosting I ate
shit Beetle murdered Jim Gavin ate shit
so I'm watching one of my heroes Jim
gavan eating shit it's a late Friday in
German second show Friday always brutal
I know so this isn't I I just learned
that you can say dragging I'm not
dragging Jim what do you mean you know
I'm not putting him down okay I'm saying
like we both did bad we're both sweating
he agree they were saying meow to him
you know from Super Troopers they were
going meow meow they wouldn't stop
saying it brutal and Jim got off and
this is in my first five years of stand
up very formative years Jim told me two
things on this weekend I remember a lot
one he said uh there's some crowds you
don't want to kill for and that was huge
I didn't I had never heard that I was
just like I thought we were cake and
cake is delicious to every look I'm not
for everyone that's the that's sort of
what I'm saying is like if you are for
everyone you're not for me so you're not
for everyone cuz like I don't like
things that are for if you think I'm
funny I should hate myself that's right
so we both ate shit and and for the
first time in my life I was like oh my
God I felt good for bombing I felt like
I was in the the better not the better I
was in the group I wanted to be yep and
then Jim gavan becomes a stadium
comedian and those people fucking hated
him so who's right nobody yeah but Jim
started figuring out who he was for the
other thing he told me I remember that
weekend I was supposed to do 10 minutes
which is impossible impossible and I
wanted to do 10 minutes and then they
gave me like five minutes of
announcements like Tuesday is wacky hat
day and all this shit sure sure sure so
I did my set then I do the announcements
and they're like you went long and I was
like but I did I did the announcements
and they're like the announcements count
towards your time and I felt humiliated
because as much of a confident blow
heart I can seem I was very fragile and
I felt bad that's also like just a power
it's five minutes each shit no no no the
correct response is each shit I can't
say that but this is someone who it's
incredible sorry to just get so granular
but I think people are into it um is
that CL we don't have a union we don't
have a every Club there's some
franchises would have been great if we
had a union at Jimmy Hoffa type go the
announcements don't count toward his
time the kid does his act you want last
time trim the announcements he breaks
his knees I would have loved that I just
mean like these are just people that
start comedy clubs in random places
probably wanted to be comedians who
knows whatever founder syndrome they
have like I've dealt with so many Club
owners in the beginning like who just
will power playay you for no reason and
you're just like I became a comedian
because I'm trying to get love from junk
strangers why are you bullying me about
you and you look back now and you're
like I see what that person was doing
yeah well in a way they were doing what
we're all doing I was going for Love by
doing my set they were going for a
feeling of superiority sure because he
could have gone like ah next time do
mine he there's a way that could have
been communicated I'm at the point where
I'm like there's no such thing as bad
news there's no such thing is saying
it's the way you say it no I agree
because we need you to do 10 minutes
including the announcements isn't
actually you weren clear in the first
yeah hey I wasn't clear so sorry wa it's
just pick on some on your own I I hate
that shit but then Jim who was my Jimmy
haa they left the room and I'm I'm there
I I feel like you know an inch tall I
I'm not good with confrontation so I
feel bad and Jim goes He leans over Jim
doesn't really know me that well and he
goes in five years they'll be begging
for it can you can you can you give this
man a cake can we send him a cake he's
just the best but these little angels
you know what I mean these tiny
kindnesses and I I try to do that as
much as I can but it was and it was done
for me and it's so lonely bill was the
same way bill I
remember I was talking about that I I I
was married at the time my first wife
and I he was trying to help me I didn't
realize it but he was like he's like why
don't you why don't you have any jokes
about your wife and I was like because I
love my wife and he goes that's your
angle and here I am 20 years later and I
have a hunk about like I love my wife
and like isn't that you're not going to
hear that a lot I say that in the
special I go you're not going to hear
that a lot no at comedy shows and that
is the angle but that's like that's you
know the difference between middling and
headlining that being the second comic
on the show who's opening for the
headliner is the headliner you got to
like go further yeah yeah and Bill was
telling me go further don't be afraid
and I'm not trying to force this that's
very spiritual it's like accept yourself
don't be afraid don't resist you're
innocent go up and show them even your
your
flaws I and show it and laugh at it I
just saw this someone uh Rick Rubin just
sent me this Instagram of Joanie
Mitchell talking um about creativity and
she said if you have writer block it
means you're afraid to say how you feel
right now that's pretty good that's all
it is yeah you're just afraid to say how
you feel right now I'll tell you this if
you have writer block I bet you go to
bed and you still have an evening's
worth of Dreams which means you have the
capacity and the natural ability to
create huge yeah multi- twisting story
arcs and your dad is a clown and you're
yelling at your brother it's all in
there I but if I I I'd rather say I have
writers block because otherwise I'd
probably just have to like cry no
exactly right yeah this is my out I to
not have to feel stuff believe me I get
it
I'm gonna blame a fake wall a fake block
like what does that even mean a block a
writer's block what does that even mean
I always picture tofu like oh really
I but it's funny my wife is not a
comedian and I've watched she rubs off
on me so much I call her she's like I
call her a love genius she's just a
genius at loving people and she's taught
like I feel like Bigfoot I'm like friend
like she teaches me how to be a friend
and not to be a sociopath and all these
things I don't I'm not a sociopath you
know connect with people engage with
people not always think about your work
and all she really she rescued me from
the weird woods and I rescued myself I
was smart enough to go with but but the
jungle of just like of I just knife in
your teeth I'm talking to this person
and just trying to steal their
personality for a script yeah exactly
look how Whitney's doing her hands you
should have the mom character in that
script she should be doing this and what
I'm insulted you said mom even though
I'm
pregnant like literally a mom and I'm
like yeah I'm not old enough to play a
mom yet it's on my mind not a TV mom you
could you could be a play mom like
theater could be like a like a
commercial maybe like Bounty paper
towels maybe Sunny D yeah but Val what
was I saying Val Val is a love genius
teaches you how to comport yourself in
the world yeah but I was oh something I
taught her so I was saying she T teaches
me a lot and I one of the things that
I've watched her you wouldn't think or
at least I don't think people would
think that living with a comedian would
actually be psychologically very healthy
because all I do is practice being okay
with how I feel so much so that I can
say it to people and deal with it I say
you know the I do the shows for free the
money is for me going back to my hotel
and being like why did I say that about
my mom that's what you're getting that's
what the money is for but it's actually
beautiful sh after bur you said it
because that's how you feel sometimes
and it's good to let that out so I watch
my wife she she was already hilarious
but I'm watching her like get
comfortable with like a dark joke or
something she'll make a dark joke about
something that she's going through and
I'm like that's the stuff that's the
lightsaber that like goes right through
it like make a fucking brutal joke about
the darkest thing in your life and
you're like therapy or the clown therapy
or the clown your choice we'll teach you
the same thing and not all Comics but
Comics have taught like big J so another
I've told this story many times but the
biggest shame of my life was that I was
like I I used to joke I never sat on
stage because I don't know but I go as a
Christian I had to come out as straight
you know I mean like it's it's just as
embarrassing to be like vagina I like
him you know like you had to be like and
I remember at the time I was like God it
was Brut it's so weird it's like
thinking about another person I was
always trying to not jerk off I was
always trying to not look at pornography
which has just become so available on
the internet and it was embarrassing uh
and the shame that I carried around and
one time we're at the seller I'm not
going up I'm just hanging out getting
bullied and uh that's what you should be
ashamed of yeah that's right it's so
much worse that was the self that's
mental masturbation yeah BDSM yeah wow
okay they don't even have a porn for you
no no and I was getting off on both I
was like yeah more
hummus there's no amount of humus that
can soothe the burn from walking toward
the table at the cellar where the comics
are I mean I I got I have to like
stretch first yeah of course I still am
like okay just don't it's fine like and
then it's so much nicer now Josh gam in
is
there it's like it's it's so much
sweeter I I don't know what that walk is
just it's like walking down the hallway
of high school I get it it's going to
the hard day it's going to the hardware
store for milk is what it is is you're
like I'm gonna I'm gonna get love here
and then you're like I I'm all about
hanging with comics and I do sit at the
table and I like it but at a certain
point if something isn't working you
have to ask yourself why do I keep doing
it and you have to ask yourself if
you're unconsciously reenacting the
trauma patterns of your youth is it
familiar for you to be abused or I'm
saying lowercase a abused but like if do
you like someone being mean to you and
around the time I met Val my wife I was
like my wife I was like oh I don't have
to do this like there's other kinds of
there's other flavors of people and the
narcissism of thinking they're even care
that you're walking toward the or or
them going Whitney's coming she did the
roast is she going to make fun of me
it's either they're just as insecure as
you are or they're the my therapist
always saying like we're obsessed with
what people think about us until we
realize they're just not yeah they're
just doing other things like oh
Whitney's here great I thought you I
took narcissism from another way I I
would take it because at least they were
paying attention to me it was negative
attention sure but I was getting it I'm
a piece of shit in the center of the
universe I exist yeah I exist at least
this guy knows I'm or he calls me that
guy or whatever but uh but I'm using
them to hurt myself
I'm like I'm just using you to cut
myself there's just much better ways
to you know feel love yeah no it's it's
it's just an old like old thing any I
agree with that with comedy too it's
like you don't have to there's a certain
point where I realize this sometimes
when I'm like I have a complicated
relationship with social media everyone
does and probably should frankly um but
when I post sometimes I'll be like what
if Chris Rock used like one I'll think
of one person's approval and I feel like
sometimes it's a comic when you're like
okay I know how to get laughs I know how
to be funny now I'm kind of just doing
this like is Will Bill think this is
funny like you start sort of looking for
respect from your peers well because if
the Journey's over you're you're dead or
that's what your fear is yeah like I
found a new daddy every month yeah yeah
yeah and I not to diagnose you I would
say I do please I would do that type of
behavior and I would recognize or I
would try to recogn
ize uh it's actually we're not afraid of
hell we're afraid of of Heaven we're
afraid of being okay yes so like I'm
okay it's to a lot of a lot of the very
very very wealthy people I know get
obsessed with Recycling and I'm like of
course because there's got to be
something you know what I mean so you're
out there you're out there taking the
sleeve off the coffee cup because there
has to be a problem sure sure sure sure
you rather be uh I need to rec miserable
and exist than Blissful and and in your
ego is mind gone and sometimes that's a
legitimate adrenaline addiction like you
know the 12ep program that I'm in ACA is
about the internal drug cabinet you know
I'm with W
but I hate ACA they book your Tor I hate
your guts ACA I ha which one is that I
hate your guts I hate your guts I hate
your guts it's such a funny phrase I
hate your
guts what is aca aca adult children of
Alcoholics justes mean you grew up in
kind of chaos for alcoholism to be
present alcohol doesn't have to be
present I've been ding on you okay great
so it's ACA it's kind of the more like
focused vers we I I love that we are
basically in there for our perfectionism
our workaholism our mothering
micromanaging martyring and when you say
allanon I have to be like well there's
it's a better version I mean it's like
the more yeah sure traumatized version
just I have to
like qualify that I had it harder or
something um but it's uh like every
program thinks of the graduate program
and addi like it's a graduate program
and we're like well it's a graduate
program na is like we're the graduate
program whatever um and so we do it we
can but um the internal drug cabinet so
instead of doing using heroin or cocaine
or whatever it is it's the creating
chaos adrenaline being in toxic
relationships to get that hit of
cortisol adrenaline which turns into
dopamine right so you're kind of
subconsciously just you know if you have
to be somewhere at 5: it takes a half
hour to get there you leave at
4:30 yeah like a big part of recovery is
going like you leave at 4:15 to allow
for life to happen and so that you're
not constantly in that mode yeah it's
funny Richard gory says we're all
addicts he's big in the AA world and he
says we're all addicted to our own way
of thinking I was like oh my God that is
is that good you know what also say
about addiction is talk about attention
I I don't uh drink anymore I didn't I
didn't go through the program but I have
a great respect for it I'm not trying to
co-opt it I'm just saying
I'm familiar with their teachings and
you go to Soul cycle I go to Soul
cycle it's amazing how many things on a
real bike though I just do laps around
them and go you guys are going
nowhere you guys are going
nowhere this is the graduate program I'm
doing skids the teachers like Peter it's
amazing how I don't know if this is just
an LA thing but every cult exercise
class just says AA slogans now oh really
yeah one day at a time guys totally it
works if you work it it's all that wow
if you want to get something you've
never gotten you got to do something you
never done it's like if it's hysterical
it's historical like it's just you're
like this is just AA but like why do I
have to be the AA S no they're all very
similar yeah well truth is truth uh but
what I would say about alcohol when I
used to drink is I was like that was the
only thing that gave me as much
attention on demand as I wanted you know
what I mean I would drink it and it
would it's it's doing you you know what
I mean it's not ignoring you it's
interesting like it might be horrible it
might give you a hangover but it's like
at least it's fucking you up I think my
biggest fear being embarrassment is kind
of what saved me from having a drinking
problem because I the main addiction a
joke about that I go I like to drink
alone fewer people to apologize to genus
and that is that was back when I wasn't
uh strong in myself enough to do a joke
like that so I think I had it I never
did it but I was like that's what Bill
bur would be like that's the angle
that's the one to do of course it is but
but now I don't drink so I can't do it
fuck I'll have to start drinking do no
but that embarrassment I bad not to make
it about me and I'm just saying like I
would do a show where there was free
booze go home and drink at home and I
have a very a hyper rational mind where
I'd just be like in this regard I'd be
like why would I want you to see me
being like you look like my uncle like
why would I want that go home talk to
John Wick yep yep he doesn't remember
anything it's like when I had food stuff
which you know you're eating the sheep
cake alone in your car I'm not going to
order the dessert at a restaurant where
like I'm like this is about accumulating
as much shame as possible and making a
building a secret right it has to be in
secret right yeah no it wants get the
proper yeah shame hits just you and also
drinking and doing drugs like I've
always been so insecure that I'm not
smart and I'm like why would I do
something that makes me less smart in
public in front of people that's I that
I completely understand and also
something of when you have restrictive
eating you don't want to drink like
sometimes it's funny when one addiction
saves you from another addiction which
is like you don't want to drink if
you're restricting food because it's
just you're just look at his calories
yeah no I've done that yeah you're like
I don't drink because I I'm anorexic I
had a joke about that too I was like I'm
doing a juice Fest and I was and I go
mostly fermented which was true cuz at
the end of a day of juice fasting I
would drink wine and I was like what do
you do yeah but when you drank did you
like the the definition or what I would
hear a lot in double winners meetings is
when I drank I felt normal I felt that a
little bit with weed which is why I had
to put the weed down a little bit
because I was like this is how everyone
else thinks yeah everyone else is just
present and in the moment and accepts
themselves and they're not worrying
about things and I was like this can't
be good I have with weed I have a fail
safe there because it does make me so
foggy so I if I smoke weed which I
actually did a couple ago and it was
great mostly because the day after I
I'll have a weed hangover and it just
makes me like I'm like you're saying I'm
just like hello I'm just like right
there there's a line at the grocery
store fiddle d d you know what I mean
it's nice to just be kind of dumb
sometimes too I loved it it was great it
was fine but the problem is uh I don't
feel the the pull with weed because if I
if then I smoke it the next day then I
like I have a show tonight I'll go up on
stage and I won't be able to to do what
I do and I'm like well that addiction is
way better than no work is work wins
every time work wins and also just being
able to like I feel like it takes effort
to be in fact I don't think I I
definitely believe it takes effort and
energy to be happy to like make the
right even the right mental Frameworks
and choices and how am I going to think
about this and if I'm stoned or
certainly when I was hung over you'd
just be kind of like we are all fucked
you
it was easier to go that way so I was
just like try to find uh better
addictions I I I don't think I don't
think I'm doing stand up I used to in
the beginning I would do standup solely
for the hit for the like they saw me
razzled Dazzle and I don't feel that as
much anymore it feels more
compartmentalized that's something I do
but I don't do it I try to do it as
little as possible can I ask about your
like regimen for that work that goes
into being happy is it like a a you wake
up you like do you have a sure before
you start your day I mean you're right
on the money right every it's all about
the beginning mental hygiene yeah I find
talk
about familiar trauma patterns I I do
cold exposure uh do you know that is it
the cold plunge or the cryo freeze PL
you're getting in the water getting in
that water doing the damn thing and I
love it and I don't I I have some
theories on why I love it but like that
is a that when you start your day by
doing something that you didn't want to
do doing something hard yep it's funny I
this isn't an AA thing but I always Val
and I always say the thing you want is
on the other side of something you don't
want and that's just a law of the
universe of this weird thing we're doing
yeah like it's why heroin doesn't work
you know what I mean like the way the
receptors of your brain work they burn
out they multiply now you need more and
sometimes you die it doesn't work like
the feel-good buttons don't work but
what does work is uh consenting to
something unpleasant that then rewards
you with something pleasant I would I
would categorize standup as that as well
you know there are different altitudes
to fly at and you can choose which one
we do we're talking about a low altitude
like an earth like an earth altitude
like I like cold plunge stuff it it
boosts my oxytocin and all the good
Feelgood stuff getting in the hot tub
afterwards is incredibly wonderful I
know that's very privileged that I have
a cold point inot then I just go are we
already happy because we have a there's
a hot tub like just knowing I know a lot
of miserable motherfuckers with hot tub
that's a really good point in fact more
of the people I know that own hot tubs
are right right so I was just going to
say you can just take a cold shower then
take a hot shower that's just as well
but um the other altitude that I was
just going to float your way because it
seems like you might enjoy this I don't
think the ego this idea of Whitney
Cummings or this idea of Pete which is
really just an amalgamation of what your
past your physiology your psychology or
the way your brain works look at your
face right
now I really do terrified I no I am like
a big fan of your brain and I'm excited
what you're going to say I hope you like
it and I'm trying to not formulate a
resp it's part of my job to be ready to
say oh I know but I'm a podcaster you
don't have to I know to be ready to say
something after you say something but I
genuinely want to be in the moment and
listening no I understand I struggle
with the same thing too as I'm talking
this is the first time I've ever listen
to someone and I'm just like you're like
me
withing
listen I'm like I say to B I'm like how
are you working them she's like what you
know what do you would I'm like all
these like retorts and comebacks I'm
just trying to like bat them all away
jealousy all of it I'm genuinely just no
you're on camera listening it's never
happened I think it's important the ego
can't be
satisfied it's like sadguru says this if
you own the entire Earth everything was
yours how long before you want Mars you
you would it's just how the ego Works
more more and more Never Enough never
enough and the people who own hot tubs
they get obsessed with their recycling
so it's this endless it's always not hot
enough hot tub's not hot enough that's
right absolutely it's what the Buddhist
call the Hungry Ghost right thin neck
big belly nothing gets in so that's okay
we can make peace with that but when we
say the ego can never uh be happy or at
peace except for brief moments when you
get what you want this is rert Spyro
when you get what you want so uh you get
a new show or whatever I don't know what
you want you get a new special the
reason you're happy this is what rert
says and I believe him is is not the
thing because you also know you're
special having your special that'll fade
you know that that feeling isn't
consistent you can't always remember you
have a special and feel happy that
network will literally disappear in the
next six months if people if enough
people don't watch this they're going to
yank it in a year this is a lease true
oh yeah no I did same same same I can't
Bank on that the reason you feel happy
when you get something isn't the thing
it's because in that moment your ego
finally got what it wanted so there's
the cessation of desire you no longer
are resisting reality which is something
you can do all the time but when you
stop resisting so they say this the
great way the Dow isn't difficult for
those who have no preferences right so
in that moment you get the thing and
it's not the thing it's that the the
monkey mind that's always next next next
next Mars Mars Mars finally calms down
and you not your ego but you as
awareness are revealed and the quality
of what you really are your
Consciousness isn't can't be happy or
unhappy it's made of a feeling you might
call happy it's made of a feeling you
might call fulfilled or peaceful or
boundless or infinite I like that you
say spacious yeah spacious is a great
word what does it mean well not clinging
yeah right even to a good feeling so I
like talking about this because even as
we're saying it I could postpone my
happiness I'm not even talking about
Pete's happiness I'm talking about the
happiness that I am that aware field
within which everything appears right
now you're a phenomenon in that
awareness the field itself
you can say is it okay does it need this
podcast to go well or will it be fine
either way the real who you are because
making Pete happy is sort of a bitch
that's why I'm dunking in cold water and
chasing specials and stuff that's fine
it's not like I don't do that but when I
was driving there I was listening to
yach rock and just kind
of tripping out on what what is hearing
my voice right now awareness how do you
know your experience there's something
in you that is aware if you ask yourself
this is Rupert spyra please look him up
he's incredible paraphrasing but anybody
can do this you don't have to be a woo
woo hippie you can just say am I aware
and then look check say am I
aware and you find but it's not an
object it's not a place there's no shape
or color to it it's just it's this thing
and the more not as a thought experiment
that you identify as
awareness uh the more you rest in your
nature which is spacious Blissful peace
and that is I achieve that more and more
throughout the day don't get me wrong I
have horrible moments yesterday I was a
total bitch I was fasting so you take
take food away from me it's harder to do
right but you feel like that pays off in
the long run but I'm just saying yeah
yeah we can talk about that but more and
more I'm
good do you mind if we don't
dude I don't want to talk about it I'm
want a fast from talk hearing about that
from high performers yeah fuck off
strong boundary no I I just love that
men have Eating Disorders Now isn't it
fun I'm like I starved myself my entire
teens and 20s no I I yeah it worked now
I wanted to now you've got me defensive
no no no but I don't have to I've had
David Sinclair on I've had we've I'm go
for it knock yourself out it's we I
don't even want people to do it okay it
works for me okay but not not just
because I started my but because it
changed my relationship to food but
that's all wonderful oh that's genius I
don't binge and then the bitch of it is
it's like they teach you karate but they
also teach you the discipline to not use
it yep that's sucks so I fast and I'm
like tomorrow I'm going to a fucking pre
but then you're clean and you wake up
and you're like why do I want to ruin
this good feeling it's really just doing
the hard thing it's hard cold punch same
thing but Rich Ro said that to me he was
like watch out because that can be
another addiction you fast for one day
one out two and I'm like I I don't have
that one I can't wait to
I'm good that see sounds like a you
thing Rich I'm going to eat you right
now we're taking a quick break from the
great Pete Holmes to talk
about merch when I started podcasting an
online store was literally the furthest
thing for my mind now I sell my book
right behind me look at it it's go
flying like hot cakes uh I sell my book
because it is so easy all because I use
Shopify Shopify is the global Commerce
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your bath from the launch your
online shop stage to the first real life
store stage all the way to the did we
just hit a million orders stage Shopify
will help you grow whether you're
selling scented soap or offering outdoor
outfits Shopify will help you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system wherever and whatever you're
selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading cont
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less effort thanks to Shopify magic your
AI powered Allstar so I had a a
breakthrough with Shopify when I found
the tab where you can find out who
bought what you sold and where they're
from so what I did business brain over
here is I catered my next tour based on
where the most sales were happening so
Chicago Dallas Austin Denver St Louis
y'all were the cities who bought my book
the mostest so I figured why not use the
data I got from Shopify to go to the
cities where you got like me you really
like me so I can come sign your books if
you haven't already sold them at a yard
sale or regifted it to someone at work
which by the way do not do that you will
be called into HR and immediately get
fired my book is considered an unwanted
Advance Shopify I love you know that
Shopify Powers 10% of all e-commerce in
the United States and Shopify is the
global force behind all birds rothis and
Brooklyn and and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries whoo Plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your success every step of the way
because business B businesses that grow
they grow a Shopify you know what
Shopify you can clip that if you want
and use it as your main
ad I'm just I'd like to just publicly
give you permission to use that is your
is your you don't even have to pay me
you could replace the cha-ching you
could replace the cha-ching that you
have patented that is your signature
with whatever I just did I'm not reading
it again Pat keep going I said what I
said sign up for $1 per month trial
period and Sh to Shopify
spell I wanted to say does Shopify sell
speech
therapists ah sign up for $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com Whitney all
lowercase go to shopify.com Whitney now
to grow your business no matter what
stage you're in shopify.com
Whitney chaing
okay so what I was saying the end yeah
that was the end but like oh I was
saying it's not just a
belief that you are awareness it's not
just fun if you believe you're awareness
you can be in my group and we can get
together and talk about and sing songs
to awareness and tell people we
celebrate awareness holidays and when I
die you can give me an awareness eulogy
it's not even about that it's about
right now when I remember that I
am that which is a A Ware of my
experience the clouds lift and I
remember myself and myself is made of
Peace that's the piece that passeth
let's use the Kings passeth
understanding that's the piece Beyond
understanding because circumstantial
happiness and circumstantial peace is a
fucking bitch game it's stupid and who
knows better than us we're affirmation
junkies going out that was a gift for me
I actually I went so far into it I was
like oh this isn't working that's that's
a gift gift that's that's the master
class the amount that you have um the
level of clarity you've achieved the
amount of work you've done I ha when
people say that shit like you've done a
lot of work whatever I'm just trying to
get to the question of what if you're
like what's wrong with you no I'm not
can you say that again a different way
um uh one more time come again no is
just the plant medicine the all the work
you've done yourself is there a level of
Consciousness you don't recommend
getting to
well yeah no Pete doesn't recommend any
of it okay because it's the it's the end
of Pete yeah like I'm just so look
because I've never done MDMA I I've
there's a buo and the Frog and the and I
see people that are I'm like do I I
remember I don't know this was maybe
like five years ago this is going to
sound self aggrandizing or like bragging
um I went into do some love addiction
work and then I was you know hardcore in
my Island I'm doing EMDR and I'm all
this stuff and my therapist did say
something to me and she was like um just
be careful how much work you do just so
you know there's going to be less and
less people you can date it gets lonlier
and lonelier I actually really agree
with that I there she's gonna say you're
going to lose a lot of friends when you
get healthy the sick get angry and so
it's just that's a good one you really
have to prepare for how lonely this
might get I love JayZ they they he says
my friend say you've changed I'm like
you think I did all that work to stay
the same same and I'm like yeah that's
great you know so so I just am curious
like is there a level of Consciousness
that you don't wish on your worst enemy
no well look the reason I said Pete
doesn't like any of it is because Pete
doesn't get to come the reason why
psychedelics sound like a bad idea to
Whitney is because it is a bad idea for
Whitney it's a great idea for your aw to
go away yes she I've smoked 5 Meo DMT
that's the toad Pete didn't
go you think Pete got to sit at the
right hand of God
hey what does l do this thing yeah where
you from if your ego Comes This is a
ramdas thing it's in be here now if your
ego comes with you into those places
that's psychosis that's what psychosis
is yeah if you if Pete thinks he's Jesus
he's in a looney bin if my awareness
thinks it's the same awareness that
everyone shares that's that's a
different but then you're just talking
about it you you understand the
difference yes but we have to get
over what we need to tell ourselves over
and over on this on this journey or I
have to tell myself over and over is
like you're innocent there's nothing to
do yeah you're already there all we need
to do if you want to experience that is
remove the impediments and that that is
where we kind of clean up you got to
clean up before you wake up and I'm all
for that but it's right it's right here
it's it's right it's right here so more
on your morning you wake up yeah and you
is this is a good morning I do go
through phases where I stagnant and I I
kind of don't do anything but in a great
morning I get up before my wife and
daughter and I'm in the cold plunge they
there's Neuroscience to this that like
doing the thing I don't know what the
chemical is or the hormone is but they
say doing things you don't want to do is
easier in the morning so do them in the
morning if it's exercise or whatever so
I get up and I get in the cold plunge
while I'm still hot for bed you have
music you have when in there yeah no
when I get out of the cold plunge I do a
big like sun salutation with my feet on
the ground okay like an earthing kind of
thing okay and that's where I repeat I
repeat certain things to
myself they would sound crazy to you one
of them is forgiveness offers everything
I want that's a that's a little it's
also like R Pete re like repeat is just
R like email re repeat
I'm not sure I follow this Rift it's
like regarding Pete I mean that's I
don't know you think oh you think it's
okay is what you're saying no I'm just
saying like you do you know what I mean
my tism just came out a little like
regard you know how an email would be
like yeah Ray repeat yeah it's your
names in it that's
all like I just it just was a little
poignant there for a minute I love it
and I everyone repeats stuff but for you
especially
like named after you it was like named
after you there just a lot of ways I
said this someone the other day someone
said something about Silicon Valley like
criminals and I was like does anyone
else think it's weird that it's
literally silly con is the name yeah and
it bombed it was just a conversation
with oh I had an opener where I'd go uh
my name is Pete some of you may
recognize me some of you might be
cognizing me for the first time that
joke is
ungettable
recognizing so I'm way on the Spectrum
with you that feels like great written
it's like that's a great written some
things are good written but I kind of
was like if you're going to be a bunch
of con artists that make silly shit yeah
silly don't call it silly con it's right
there in the name call don't call the
airport a terminal I
like don't call the gate C4 while we're
at your gate is C4 I'm like what I can't
say bomb but you can name a gate after
one that's wild wild yeah I know um cian
section C-section right Caesar was
stabbed to death oh wow it's a C I'm not
sure if that's why but it's a little
like rhinoplasty Rhino your nose they're
aware they have a problem that's a
Seinfeld bed oh God these women are
aware they have a problem yes do we have
to bring rhinos into it it's cuz Rhino
means nose that's where you ruin it you
just are like you look like a rhino we
need to get this solved well the his
tags were we're going to perform a qall
to me this will cure your
chromia these are medical terms of
course what a great comment anyway I'm
so sorry then you repeat that many times
yes some affirmations I believe in that
I just think what you you know how when
you eat uh if you eat a cupcake for
breakfast you'll crave sugar all day I
think if you start your day with a bad
thought you'll kind of be some sometimes
I wouldn't say I'm rough on I'm not
rough on myself I'm pretty accommodating
but if I have if I catch myself just
sort of seeing with comic eyes
everything's I'm comparing everything
I'm contrasting everything making jokes
about everything I just go like can you
just
stop yeah just stop or it's like once
you've taken two bites of the cupcake
you're like well I might as well eat the
whole thing I had two futons I might as
well eat the whole sleeve right Brian
Brian sorry um always think about you
whenever I talk about food um and I've
started and this is I don't know if I
recommend this to anyone because I'm
kind of back to going to some more
rudimentary things
um Abraham Hicks has this morning medit
I don't know how people feel about her I
don't know if she's like the you know
Walmart of I think you're self-help I
don't know but she does like this
morning medit it's like 20 minutes long
I've just been listening to it every
morning and it's like today will be the
day of Mo of my most gratitude like it's
just kind of like a positive thing half
of it makes sense half of it's kind of
dri but it just starts me on the right
path it's like taking a vitamin in the
morning whether it works or not I took
it well you just reminded that this is
in my uh it doesn't matter it's in my
book who cares buy my book to let's go
mine are behind me whatever yeah yours
are there uh but I comedy sex got after
I get out of the um hot I feel real good
but then I jump in the pool and the
pool's real cold then I'd take a bath in
my golden coins like what is this Jesus
then I tell my to give me some I oh my
God the royal penis is clean your
highness Jesus Christ then I I snort the
Adrena Chrome Whitney what I'm going to
take one of these cameras around your
house if you don't stop this Rift my
your house is insane so any um I I put
my arms up and I look at this big
beautiful tree that no one else could
afford this
tree ha you and I say yes thank you that
is a big but that's what I'm saying the
great way is not difficult for those who
have no preferences so the way to be
some people are listening to this in
traffic and that is a great practice
don't postpone your happiness till when
you get there you can't get there if I
just get this thing I'll be happy though
it doesn't work because when you get
there this is ramas you eat the ice
cream then you want water then you have
to pee then you're bored you watch TV I
feel bad I E ice cream yeah that you can
add that level to it it's a whole other
trip but then you have to go to bed now
you woke up now you have to work now you
need money it's like it never stops so
like the whole thing it's it's like life
is what happens when you're busy making
plans or whatever it's like at a certain
point you realize that these these
slowdowns or these impediments are
actually really great opportunities to
kind of just go like yes thank you and
when you're sad I have a friend going
through a hard thing and I was like look
I don't want to I'd rather feel it than
fix it like I'm just here with you but
at the end of the conversation I was
like yes thank you your nervous system
does not know what to do with yes thank
you yeah I I had a um so just to clarify
you there were two mantras that you
mentioned resist nothing and yes thank
you the first one was forgiveness offers
everything I want oh sorry I have I
don't know why I have maybe you said
this somewhere else forgiveness offers
everything I want yeah I love that
that's a hard one and it always helps me
to remember uh we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace yeah
forgiveness always poison hoping they
die always selfish yeah it's also it's a
misunderstanding of who everybody is and
it's very lonely and and it's very I
spent a lot of time forgiving people
that never harm me in the first
place yeah I I'm totally with you and
the thing this is from A Course in
Miracles but it's like if you want to
experience forgiveness you have to
practice by forgiving everybody because
by holding grudges and and hating and
judging it's it's just a mirror the
whole thing is a mirror so you forgive
them not even just for you but for the
whole thing the whole thing is forgiving
itself when you forgive somebody there's
this a a step in 12 steps where you you
apologize to people you make an amends
if you know where it's due and then you
do it every night just to kind of clear
your Consciousness making amends um and
uh and I remember when I first went into
program uh my sponsor said to me
everyone that you think owes you an
apology is who you owe an apology to I
like that just as like a little and
you're like what do you mean this person
did this to me and this to me and then I
turned around and went like oh yeah I
had unreasonable expectations oh yeah I
was trying to control you oh yeah I was
like I was passive aggressive and I was
trying to change you and fix you like
yeah that's right that reminds me
another great teacher that changed my
life is Byron Katie who wrote a book
called loving what is which is the title
you know it's good when even the title
is just like oh that paid out yeah but
you know you do something called the
work at real quick you could say
something like my mom doesn't understand
me that's what the first step is to find
the the language of the pain really say
it in fact write it down you have to
write it down and you have to let it
talk honestly and you say my this isn't
even that good because usually they're
more embarrassing but my mom doesn't
understand me and then you ask these
four questions you say is it true you go
yeah yeah she doesn't understand can you
really know it's true can I do one yeah
sure um you're already on board what if
the third step is like show your butt
hole great let's go go God forbid I be
an only fans billionaire um a butt
billionaire what if what if okay the guy
I'm
dating um
uh it has to be like they've wronged me
it doesn't appreciate takes me for
granted okay so is that a good one sure
yeah that's a great one okay uh you're
like it's
true uh so let's call him Bill Bill Burr
your boyfriend y
shipped the only person who shit list I
don't want to be on is his wife okay
yeah true uh okay we'll say uh Mark okay
Mark takes me for granted um I I would
say Mark should appreciate me more might
be helpful okay
um is it
true not necessarily because it's not
happening right what do you mean it it's
not he appreciates you as much as he is
so it's to say he should is sort of
arguing with reality I you know what I
mean I have get it you're like you're
like shaking your fist going you should
but he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't
appreciate you more he appreciates you
exactly as much as he appreciates you
it's already fun but I and you're going
you should appreciate me more he doesn't
I don't but the irony is that I identify
as an insecure person sometimes but now
I'm like this person doesn't appreciate
how all of a sudden I have a very high
uh selfworth yeah which is fine I'm not
even I know but it's just a weird thing
that I've already noticed but the second
step of like can you know the second
question is can you know for let's say
you do say yes it's true he should
appreciate me okay can you absolutely
know for sure that it's true and then
this is where we get kind of interesting
and then sorry you've already made me
realize my definition for being
appreciated is like more texts right
well that's another thought we can look
at Mark should know Mark should
appreciate me in the way that I
appreciate other people like Mark should
or the next one everyone should
appreciate people the same way or there
is a there is a right way to appreciate
my way and by the way only person I've
ever dated who has explicitly sent a
text saying I appreciate you that's so
funny the only one so then it was like
yeah well it's just us Whitney you know
what I mean there's only there's only
one of it so
uh can you know but then the interesting
area for me is we don't know how much he
appreciates you we know that he doesn't
text you but we don't really know that
he doesn't appreciate you you know what
I mean because do people always tell you
how they feel are do people even know
how they feel it's very merury in there
we go around acting like it's very cut
and dry but like my dad is a purple
tornado of confusing emotions and I go
he doesn't I don't know it's all in
there he's a lot um so the third one is
uh how do you feel when you believe
markk should appreciate me
more I this one's easy just how do you
feel yeah I
feel um sad and insecure and I beat
myself up because I'm going oh I'm
recreating childhood circumstance yeah
so you feel guilty a little as shame
embarrassed embarrassed you probably
feel angry not enough unloved worthless
isolated alone scared okay I'm just
saying like way if we're going to really
go like not pretty enough am I getting
older
ugly mortal it's all not interesting oh
my God yes I would say almost any
feeling has pretty much every feeling
but let's let's look at it all of that
then the next one is how would you feel
if you didn't believe it if you didn't
believe that I'd find someone else to
believe it with that's fine but how
would you feel if you believe that he
appreciated you in my I'd feel amazing
and all my problems would be solved yeah
you'd feel appreciated you'd feel loved
you'd feel safe seen seen seen cuz I
valid respected spacious understood
clear happy Carefree Carefree light free
yeah we've already shown that we don't
know it's true and and there's two ways
to feel and you're choosing the shitty
one so this is the this is like exposure
therapy yeah then the last one this one
I don't know how it'll work because it's
different for everybody but you do the
turnaround which is there's lots of
turnarounds here Mark does appreciate me
what's four ways that's true one is he
textt me I appreciate you so we already
have one what are three more you could
do that yeah and you find them my dad
does understand me my dad knows this
this joke about he my dad said that to
me he remembers me and how often I I
don't think I've ever said to someone I
just want you to know I appreciate you
yeah like everyone could have that story
about me as well that's what I'm saying
is we're making our own reality I I'm
going I'm going to show this person how
much I appreciate them because when
Christmas rolls around I'm G to get them
a gift yeah but I don't I'm not doing
words of affirmation with them at all
I'm all of a sudden expecting some words
of affirmation I give that that's the
next turnaround is I should appreciate
Mark
more it's fun I should understand my dad
more I don't understand my dad it's like
when you point one finger at someone
else you point three at yourself it's
kind of just whatever I'm accusing
someone of doing is probably what I'm
doing that's the turnar around cuz I I I
thought of that but they all have other
beliefs the the skill of the work and
this is Byron Katy the work it's all her
and it's incredible uh all of her books
are incredible but you start getting
better at identifying what is the the
baby and I don't mean that in a bad way
I just mean what do the hurt actually
say does it help you to say inner child
absolutely yeah to be like my I'm having
an inner child reaction yeah put my hand
on my chest and say I got you powerful
stuff am I allowed to ask you if I were
so a lot of people have religious trauma
fine a lot of people saw hypocrisy fine
I you mean Rel religous just oh oh no
hypocrisy I the movie oh no sorry I just
mean I think a lot of people's hang ups
on religious you you brought it up in
and I believe you're special about how
um in our business there being so much
atheism and I just to add to that like
you don't believe in God but you do
believe in like astrology let's just
calm down with the with the atheism you
guys you know what I mean and I'm seeing
all these other little kind of religions
pop up whether it's keto and I don't
know yeah I know what you mean Wellness
you know crystals whatever everyone's F
whe Q andon you know whatever it is we
all you know Terror management Theory
you know we all have to have something
I'm just curious is someone who is like
now kind of going like all right I'm in
the market for a religion I identify in
many ways the way you do religious wise
but after you've seen a lot of death
there's this craving for like and plan a
funeral like the way Jewish people run a
funeral you're just like after you've
had to handle a funeral there's no they
just have it down you're like I want God
good orderly Direction that's what we
say in program so I always you know I
say higher power I say God because I'm
in this program if someone were to start
back up with the Bible per se like where
would they where would you recommend
someone start who wants to get back on
the wagon well okay I I I love this
question and I can't wait to answer it I
do want to say that there are different
levels and one one of them that we're
talking about is uh tribal identity and
that sounds like a nasty no no I don't
mean it that way uh a a clan a tribe is
one of the things that you get from
religion in fact it's Rea asan did my
podcast it was like 90% of religion is
to have a cultural and tribal identity
and that's fine uh I'm not putting that
down for me at a certain point that
didn't cut the mustard and that's okay I
don't go to church uh that's fine my my
my my snoody I want to be like you the
point is to never leave church you're
supposed to maintain that connection but
anyway I understand the covered dish and
the and the funerals and the weddings
and also it's like to be against
religion is so elitist also it's like
it's also like free Child Care on
Sundays it's like there's a lot of
reasons people go is really hard yeah
and I I completely get that here's
here's I love your question though I
think that the Bible can be summarized
perfectly uh with two two stories it's
the Garden of Eden and the prodal Sun
and I think that's pretty much all you
need uh the Garden of Eden but I would
change it a little bit not change it but
you'll see the Garden of Eden is we were
in perfect Oneness uh one with God naked
so not literally naked but we were
unclothed unnamed just pure being and
one with God in the garden with God so
that's what in the garden with God does
that make sense yes you tracking with me
I why am I glazing over no I just see
you wincing in a way that usually
reserved for eating spicy
mustards
I'm well I'll say what I I'll say and
then and then you can ask uh if you have
any follow-up questions okay imagine
that there's a place you could call it
Heaven that is perfect Oneness it's
there's no separation so you are with
God and the way we discuss that or the
way that we metaphorize that is a garden
and
naked then what do we do we eat from the
tree
of Good and Evil that's Duality right so
yes and no that's the world we're in I
my brain was going and I'm sorry that I
glazed over I kind of was going oh was
Eve a a conniving bitch in this one like
did I just take that away
that there's a little uh I could see how
it could be interpreted misogynistic I I
have no tie to this story so me either I
don't meaning I don't have any need to
defend it so yeah I could see how and I
I don't my brain she's not a conniving
bitch she just listens to the snake my
brain dumb dumb bitch dumb bitch she a
dumb bitch okay good I but Adam's a dumb
bitch too he's like what are you
eating know I mean like every time any
story people are like sitcoms are so
sexist against women that all the I'm
like look at the men and sitcoms they're
literally functionally I'm not allowed
to say the word you know what I mean
they're like hey guys it's just like
everything is so sexist it's fine calm
down no it's true that's a Brian Regan
bid the guy stuck in the blinds
um isn't he great one of the best that's
so good anyway there look don't don't
don't start pulling threads on the Gard
my brain meaning you could talk about
the Garden of Eden for thousands of
years in fact we have yes here's what
I'm going to say we were in the garden
we were one with God there was a snake
the snake is our ego it's not the devil
the snake represents come into the world
come into this world no good and evil no
yes and no don't be nothing MH be have
pain and pleasure have winning and
losing come into Duality the tree of
Good and Evil so we ate it what I like
about that is we elected to do it we
wanted to do it we wanted to play this
game we wanted to dance this dance uh we
ate it and we got booted from the garden
the part that I would change is uh the
part that I think the ego wrote from
this story is then God is mad God puts
up angels with flaming swords to block
us from the garden and kicks us out and
says now childbirth is going to be hard
now you won't live forever and you'll
die all this stuff it's like a
punishment that is what I would call the
ego God that's the god that we made in
our image instead of the other way
around so I drop that part but what I
like about that story is that we were
one we elected to eat an apple to
experience Duality which is what we're
doing right now Pat's fucking over there
you're over there this is duality exist
but we know it all my daughter I watch
my daughter you're going to watch your
baby they'll be upset sometimes they'll
skin their knee you know what I mean
this is Duality but you'll also know
chocolate chip cookies and this is the
game we're playing it's okay it's a
sacrifice that Oneness made like a
mother this is rert Spyro as well
sacrifices parts of her body and her
life to what to experience to let what
do you mean I mean you're going to split
from I'm going to tear from anus if I
tear I swear to God dedendum
am I no my wife didn't okay you'll be
fine you got a huge
[Laughter]
cter if you hear the doctor go it's
coming out she's got a h gut your
gut I'm literally like thinking of
starting drinking just to keep the baby
small that is
hilarious um okay the second story so
what I remember the point is we were one
we chose we made a sacrifice to eat the
apple to enter into this sort of dance M
this experiment this play the other
story which I always say this but I'll
say it a million times I don't care uh
of all the things that Jesus definitely
said Scholars would agree that the
prodigal son is Jesus's closer right
it's like the big number yeah I think
that's the whole thing uh there's a son
he says give me my inheritance so God
gives him his the dad God gives him his
inheritance then he goes out and
squanders it that's what we're doing
fucking up there telling dick jokes and
rolling around with the pigs you know
what I mean we're just having a good old
time yeah then what happens the money
runs out your life runs out the money is
his life basically he runs out of money
he's destitute he's working with the
pigs and he's a Jew remember so working
with the pigs is like Jesus is trying to
say he's lower than low you know what I
mean and he goes in his lowest moment he
remembers his father but he doesn't go
which he should my father's a king I'll
go home he'll welcome me back he doesn't
because he's afraid of his dad he's like
he's going to see that I squandered my
inheritance my life so he goes maybe if
I go back and like throw myself before
him he'll maybe make me a servant in his
kingdom and at least I won't die so he
goes back scared to face his father but
we know the story father isn't mad in
fact I would summarize both of these
stories as dad's not mad that's what we
need now you tell me we need to know
Dad's not mad he gives him a robe he
puts rings on his fingers he washes his
feet gives him new shoes gives him the
best room in the palace they slaughter
the fat and calf all the bible stuff
meaning they had a rip and good time and
celebrated him that's the whole thing
we're afraid of God we're afraid we
think we're with the pigs we think we're
shit we think we've squandered our
inheritance we think we got kicked out
of the garden when what we really need
to realize is Dad's not mad it's safe to
go home in fact you're already home
there's just kind of a movie
playing so Richard Ward to summarize
said the the point of spirituality or
mysticism or faith or whatever you want
to say is to accept that you are
accepted and this is my brain I go well
what did that Dad do when he was a child
to make him think what he wasn't going
to accept him later like what number did
he do on his self-esteem because it no
I'm just it is cuz you'd be a good
Jewish woman you'd do the good this is
what they do they they ask the stories I
know this a new in a way that seems
pretty guilty he seems like he's
overcompensating but Jesus tells stories
about this over and over about the
irrational love of God none of these get
reported one there's a great story about
uh there's always a wealthy person in
the story that they represent God
interesting and he hires three no one
tells you this when you're I know they
just tell you that your vagina's evil
and all that stuff so this guy uh it's
one of my favorite Parables he hires
three workers uh to work in his Fields
the first guy shows up at 8:00 a.m. I'm
paraphrasing works all day works from
88: am to 8:00 pm the second guy shows
up at 12 works from 12 to 8 the last guy
shows up at 6 he works from 6 p.m. to
8:00 P.M guy pays them all the same and
of course the guy that show up at eight
Hollywood is mad that's hilarious the
point of the story is you can't divide
Infinity
God loves you water makes you wet you'd
like to play this little I was going to
say bitch it's going to ruin the clip
for the religious folks but you want to
play this little bitch game of earning
it oh God loves you when you're good you
mean like your boss at Cheesecake
Factory have a God that's better than
the boss at Cheesecake Factory who loves
you when you're good and hates you when
you're bad kick rocks but like that's
what church did to get you to pay them
right yeah for sure it was it that was
when the business of religion came in I
and I get it and there was certain
social order and different motivation
I'm not controls people I'm not it's
like what we do with Santa and kids I'm
just trying to understand that not
totally vilify it but yeah you you
create a need your soul is dirty and
it's going to go to hell you create a
time you put a clock on it tickets
tickets to Whitney's tour is only on
sale on Tuesday use
code what did I say
cter use code giant cter will you create
urgency right you're going to die and
then you provide a solution believe in
Jesus come with us that's marketing and
that's okay I'm not even I'm not even
doing new rule I'm not trying to do that
I'm just saying like that's what human
beings do the great the great little
joke God and the devil are walking God
uh picks up a stone and he goes oh it's
truth and the devil says let me organize
that for you it's what we do yeah we
ruin it but the to I I feel like you
didn't maybe you didn't hear me I'm not
sure the whole point is to accept that
you are accepted that's the whole thing
dad's not mad and it starts with you not
being mad at you forgiving you want to
be forgiven forgive you want to be loved
love you want to be free make others
free it's in the course of Miracles a
Jailer is not free with his prisoner
because you have to watch them right I
love that guess what dipshit you're in
jail too you're just on the other side
of the bars let it all go but guess what
you already did it's just you we drag
the past into this prec
look at how fresh look at how fresh this
moment is look at how wide open it is
fucking so in on this cult dude I'm so
there's no you're going to be so
disappointed you don't sell anything if
you you know you're just the remix of
all the best shit in one place you like
it I really because I quote him so much
Richard
Roar uh rert spyra SP p i r a he wrote a
book called being aware of being aware
that would change your life but you're
remixing all the best shit into one and
then there's me yeah what I like about
spirituality is it's not like Comics
they don't get mad if you say their
stuff I try to footnote them but I
couldn't just do Eddie Murphy's jokes
and say that was Eddie Murphy like
that's that's that's cheating but in
spirituality everybody kind of borrows
because it at least that's my
understanding maybe I get a cease and
assist from rert Spyro I don't know but
that would be very disappointing but I'm
just trying to get out what's helped me
yeah but you know can can you want to do
the rubbert Spyro thing yes close your
eyes without this is rert I can't do it
like he can but and I'm not even doing
it as a party trick I'm doing it as
something you can do for yourself okay
and that I do for myself close your eyes
Pat you do it too you stupid
bitch I'm gonna tighten my Cooter to
close that ey without reference to the
Past okay you're a newborn baby you're a
newborn baby you you have no past so
without referencing the past tell me
about yourself
I'm
pregnant what your eyes closed with no
past or knowing about your body oh got
it okay how would you know you're
pregnant I mean that's a good point you
just showed up so we're looking for the
self that would be aware of the feeling
of a baby in your belly and even that
you're adding the story of a feeling of
a baby in your belly it's just a
sensation tell me
about you the field within which any of
those Sensations would
appear I feel like I'm bombing that's
hilarious because Whitney I'll just help
you because I can't see you bomb you
can't really talk about it there's
nothing to you can just say I am or I so
it shows you how attached to your
stories your are you are and it it's
really trying to point you to your true
self the other one and I don't want to
freak you out because I did this with
Craig Ferguson and it freaked him out
but put your hand on the table and close
your eyes
where does the sensation of your hand on
the table appear where are you
experiencing
it just you could just no it's not a
trick here right it's here it's keep
your eyes closed I don't I don't like
looking at you no but like look it
appears as a sensation you might
visualize it as little dots right that
show up in this open spacious field
there's a sensation that shows up and if
I say where is that showing up you would
just say if you were a baby with no
spatial reference floaty kind of you'd
be like it's it shows up here it shows
up in yourself right you understand that
yes shows up in yourself now picture
Michael Jordan okay where is that is he
playing baseball or basball baseball of
course
okay so Michael Jordan playing baseball
that where does that image appear it
appears here in the same field that the
sensation of your hand appears now my
voice where is that coming together for
you where does that get processed and
known oh no here's here if it's starting
to make you anxious here open your eyes
it's not making me anxious it's just
making me realize how much I think like
when you have like epiphanies like this
and get clear like this you have to
accept how much time you've wasted doing
shit other ways guess what time doesn't
exist but all those mistakes when you're
just like G I've been so unconscious for
so long no no no no this is the best I
love that you're not anxious I got a
little worried that sometimes people get
a little spooked but to be afraid of
what you are is is is wildly insane and
what you are is is that field within
which my voice the feeling of your hand
on the table the image that you imagine
the thought the thought how has this
episode gone too long when should we
wrap it up all of that is showing up in
a spacious
pristine boundar list here's the other
one got this from Muji can you find a
boundary in this field on the other side
of which it is not can you find like a
wall and then on the other side it's not
there uh wait I'm I'm no no it's okay
maybe I'm not being clear no no no if if
there so I'm I'm picturing a wall and
then the no don't picture anything okay
so this field within which the field
feeling of your hand on the table and my
voice and all this stuff is appearing so
you can we can agree that to use spatial
it's it's it feels like a space it feels
like an empty field that is aware yes so
it's a it's a field of
awareness is there any boundary does it
end do you ever no go if you send
something out into it do you ever hit a
wall and go oh this is the end of it I'm
a flat earther so this is perfect thank
you
Kyrie that so we can say that it
is without boundary yes also uh and I
got this from Fred Davis think of a
memory from your childhood this sense of
being now think of you're a little girl
you're going swimming in that memory was
this sense of being there and was it
different does it age does it change
does it need anything does it hope Pete
likes me or is it always just this this
all encompassing ground of being that is
so yes it doesn't even bother saying
yes look at what it allows I just had a
little bit of an epiphany that I don't
know if I'm acing this but I did have a
weird Epiphany when you made me imagine
myself in a swimming pool yeah which is
that I remember being so Terri terrified
that if I peed in the pool it would be
purple remember they would tell you that
and it just made me realize the hundred
things a day parents and adults told
kids back then to just keep them scared
all the time
right like you're a bad girl and you're
and God ha or just like yeah don't
you're going to hurt yourself don't get
on that you're going to ruin your panty
hose you're G to if you pee it's going
to turn purple if you go swimming an
hour after eating you're going to get SI
like just that's how they had to control
us and I feel like I haven't I've never
thought about that about everything I do
I'm like this person's going to break
your heart you're going to suck if you
do this you're going to hurt yourself
like I'm I'm sorry if I didn't get no
that right but I saw that so clearly for
the first time that's great that's the
and we can even have compassion for that
everybody you're going to embarrass this
is the constant of am I going to
embarrass myself water yeah there's a
core negative belief you're gonna
embarrass yourself they're all gonna
laugh at you I'm hurt myself I'm going
to embarrass myself I'm going to be a
burden I'm going to cause a problem the
part that was missing was when you were
that little girl a a specific memory
don't let me give you one mine is when I
was in My Neighbor's Pool the question
that Fred Davis asks is was this sense
of
being there and was it the same or was
there a sense of being and if I do that
it's hard to do it while you're talking
about it but you're like yeah it was
this this is why when I interviewed
Norman Le on my podcast I was like do
you feel older all old people say no
your body is a phenomenon that appears
in Awareness oh in your awareness oh God
and we think because we close our eyes
it goes away it must be originating
behind our eyes or in our heads but it's
the same as a a dream based on that what
plant medicine do I need to do based on
how poorly that I you hand that you did
wonderfully I really I I I would my only
concern doing that is that it might just
be a little overwhelming when you start
getting in touch with the fact that you
are in aware field of Consciousness
sometimes that can be a little
unsettling and if that was to anybody
listening or watching just get a
weighted blanket and watch some friends
like you'll be okay like it's okay and
then when it feels safe to you can start
it's a little bit like oh you're just
flying through space yeah but what's
interesting is when you recognize
yourself as awareness uh when people are
like you see the Earth and it's so small
I'm
like buddy we're all of it there is no
size or distance or space it's all it's
like a dream it's all being made by an
out of Consciousness so it doesn't
matter if there's a nebula a 100 million
light years away that's still me and I
don't mean
Pete I no I don't want to be selfish and
keep you that much longer but can I
please just ask you as a parent um how I
I feel like this is the main question I
asked people for advice where do you
stand on telling your kids about the
Easter Bunny and Santa Claus I'm all in
all in okay because i' I just trust you
now and I'm just curious with h that I'm
all in Santa Claus is a metaphor and
it's important to te everyone's like
it's a lie as if literal truth is the
only kind of Truth interesting Richard
Rory said taught me literal truth is the
lowest level of truth I feel like it's
helpful if you want to build a bridge or
do a surgery I'm all it's how we're I
feel like I'm trying to deconstruct all
this stuff as an adult and not be
attached to all these rituals and what
but with kids yeah it's just you don't
want to Gaslight your kids kind of yeah
I I understand first of all Leela is so
smart I can see her putting it together
like I know this is a tradition and a
metaphor notal she says stuff all the
time like but he's not real she's only
five and we've never hinted that he's
not real and we'll tell her if she says
something like that I'll be like he's
real because we we believe in it it's
it's a thing that we're doing it's a
it's a way to understand Joseph Campbell
would say that Santa Claus is a metaphor
to help us understand that what is done
in secret is
rewarded you know what I'm saying so
it's the same reason I bring my daughter
a gift when I come home from the road
because your patience is rewarded and
the reward of if you're not getting an
actual gift knowing you did the right
thing when no one's watching always
feels better that's what Santa Claus is
doing yeah right but like
turning him into a Gestapo or what we do
with God turning God into a lifeguard
God and all he does is blow his whistle
and wag his finger and he's mad at you
there's a there's a danger a lot of us
are essentially worshiping a version of
of Santa Claus and I'm not putting that
down that was me for a very long time
it's okay but at a certain point you
have to go like uh it's not a pool it's
an ocean and I'm not a person I'm a fish
and there are no
rules and it is unconditional love it's
not a punitive God that's keeping score
have a God that's better than than your
boss a Cheesecake Factory that's the
language I've been looking for that's a
bit I'm working on so that's so genius I
have to write that down no one ever gets
to the Cheesecake either oh you're so
full I hate when they put the calories
in there cuz I used to get the chicken
and biscuit salads are like 12200
calories the chicken and biscuits is
1950 calories I'm like that's the
day and I used to eat that and that's
the Rock's cheat day like what it's
insane don't don't you know what we're
paying you for I don't know where any of
these statistics ever come from from but
there's one of women get half their
calories from salad dressing like salads
tend to have the most calories when in
seed oils are no good when you go to
restaurants in McDonald's they were like
this is a 1300 because it's ranch
dressing or fuck insane worth it you
want a salad dressing tip just to change
altitudes bring us back to Earth a
little bit please my favorite salad
dressing o is so you got a bunch of
greens good greens not just kale get
some fucking get some the Lesser got
some weird pesticides going these days
that's not I had a doctor say to me like
watch out for kale I was like I thought
that was the thing that's gonna Dr
McDonald Ronald McDonald Dr
Dre no I I can't speak to that I will
say that if you get a bunch of greens
like mixed greens you know spring mix
something that's kind of tasty and and
some of the the harder
ones put an avocado in it some lemon and
salt and then a little bit of like apple
cider vinegar and then just mush it up
but the mushing is the key it's kind of
gross but wash your hands and mush it up
it makes it all sloppy and and wet just
avocado so now are you eating a whole
food dressing sorry if you saw me Twitch
I can't see I knewe I was right here's
what I will say you go I I am right that
he I can't get anything past you I was
right when I said that in the beginning
I was like I have this thing with you
where I feel like I can't get anything
past you which is like it's as soon as
you said brags apple cider yeah did you
see me like twitch a little bit why you
don't like it no I'm on this she has a
theory I it's not a theory it's Bill
Gates has bought Bragg's apple cider
vinegar and he puts his appeal apples in
it it's this cover on apples that keeps
them fresh I can't stop talking about it
I don't understand he keeps his apples
fresh without Bill Gates invented this
thing that makes apples stay fresh for 3
weeks at Costco it's a peel it's this
like SCH smegma that goes over an apple
not good bad
and I'm
sorry don't bring your cter into
this and then he bought brags and is
putting his appeal apples in so there's
a lot of like natural things that are
being bought up by B like Bartz bees is
owned by Clorox I guess this is my this
is your q and on moment this is are you
Q what a disappointment I guess look I'm
always eventually right if you guys just
go down this Wormhole with me come in
the water's STM guys um but yeah so are
you suspicious of this or you feel okay
about this well I think it's I
definitely think it's Bad News Bears it
that appeal apples with whatever those
chemicals are would be going into
brags so we might need to get a
different kind of apple cider vinegar Oh
you mean the peel apples are being used
to make in the brags yeah oh cuz he
bought brags and now apparently he's
putting his I have umbrella insurance I
can say this but allegedly um protected
by satire and parody let's make a joke
real quick um about this but yeah so
he's using those it's just like a lot of
times like it's just so hard why would
you need to see this is why would you
need to preserve apples if you're going
to make them into apple cider that's a
great point
but like you're not thinking like a
psychopath I need you to step into the
brains of a psych of a billionaire
psychopath Bill Gates is poisoning us
with his uh Magic wrapped apples that he
doesn't need to preserve is it true but
the ones that need to be preserved AR
Costco but you know what's a great way
to preserve them is turn them into
appleid
cider I think for I feel like at this
point Bill Gates is watching this
podcast because I'm making this show for
made the briefing for him at this point
like I literally talk about his Sinister
yeah Antics every episode now um they
don't call me ho Rogan for nothing um do
they
no just Ron funes I'd love to be on the
whole Rogan
Experience a big break for me but like
just when you find out that like some
natural like that natural shampoo brand
Jason was bought by you know it's like
smart water was bought by
by yeah I I don't know I'm sort of like
don't don't don't you think they put in
something that they're like well you
can't change it you know look I did have
to go off Prozac when I got pregnant so
I think it's probably just that I think
we're just there I think we're nine
months off proac territory whatever that
is okay so in a couple weeks go back on
and let's see if I even remember talking
about
bades I don't know they're like are you
nesting I'm like not really but I am
like in a very deep Reddit chat room
about Bill Gates is that
count that's sleep yeah try to do that
for well because also once you like you
know you get pregnant you're like I got
to order that baby powder and like that
was full of asbest like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I like put it on my
registry formulas and stuff yeah it's
all that shit well they're now finding
that there's microplastics and breast
milk so I I don't know no yeah breast
milk is definitely if the cows are we
are too this is a macroplastic with the
job I got but the point is I guess I'm
just getting in some weird Wormhole
which is probably just the the hole that
religion would fill looking for truth
looking for order looking for routine
well I I was going to say this earlier
we really have to be care ful myself
included of course the ego loves a
spiritual path but what I'm talking
about isn't uh and what Rupert spyra
again is talking about isn't a path it's
we've done it a couple times we've
dropped into it a couple times it's
right here you are awareness what could
be more
obvious and the and the ego would like
to make that a Bill Gates Reddit room
and go like if I do this if I do iasa if
I do that if I read this book or that
book and I've read books I haven't done
I waska but I'm just saying like I've
done stuff like that and it's all part
of it but there's a real Temptation then
to become the rich person obsessed with
Recycling and go like it's the next
teacher it's the next Guru it's the next
blessing it's the next song If I could
learn the hanaman Chalisa in Hindu I
could do it it's like well or you could
just say what is it that's aware of my
desire to be enlightened and does it
need anything does it need to be
enlightened does it need to and I'm like
really worried about the people out
there who need the health tonic of apple
cider vinegar meanwhile I need to just
take care of myself yeah I
mean Bill Gates is poisoning us is Bill
I'm poisoning us I'm being poison let's
do it I don't I I don't know I love this
game well that one's easy because we
don't know how would I
feel I wonder what the the belief there
is it's like if I'm not vigilant someone
will kill
me or or is poisoning all of us and
everyone
is I guess it's like I it drives me nuts
maybe this is like a little hangup when
people get lied to when they're you're
trying to eat something healthy and then
you're getting lied too yeah you know
what I mean when people go to the zoo or
a fake Sanctuary because they think it's
rescue and they spend money and it's
actually they're abusing animals like I
hate when people get conned yeah
that's that's I think that's lovely
because we're the snitches we're Comics
we're the ones
like like here's the thing like we kind
of feel the need I still think about
there was a guy I knew on Facebook and
and he was getting heavier and heavier
and and I'm not making fun of him just
saying he was getting bigger and he
wasn't happy about it and he posted a
picture of like a yogurt drink that he
got and it was like trying finally
trying to be healthy and I was
like it was like probably a 33 gram of
sugar bullshit yeah you know what I mean
like it was marketed there's a little
kale on the cover sure sure I didn't
engage but I think about it all the time
it why does that because we were con you
know like it hurts it hurts to exploit
people I think that's a lovely impulse I
would and there's something about comics
where were the ones go look over here I
don't know about this we're kind of the
like look over up look up here look up
here type sorry
hey look up here look up here look at me
hey guys and they're right
there Three Amigos H doesn't get better
thank you so much for doing this Pete
Holmes I'm not for
everyone God damn it this is I laughed
out loud many many times I preach I
don't know why that me it's just Comics
we just don't do that I know what you
mean we just go that's funny that's
smart that's good that means a lot I'm
so touched that you like it no one's
done the ads marketed to you thing
perfect like I don't want to give it
away
I I really appreciate so makes me
angry frustrating frustrating they
wanted that to be the social clip and I
was like can't ruin uhuh one of the best
parts of the whole I do have this
feeling I go I have to think I'm for
somebody because I'm for me and I like
cter jokes and talking about the son
somebody else has to be like this guy's
what I've been looking for and I just
have to find a lot of them but you also
really I mean your podcast that you made
it weird was always so fun and funny and
quick and and joke joke joke but I think
that like one of the most brutal things
that can happen to a comic is they don't
mature or feel like they have to always
be funny I remember um to your point of
something that you heard in the
beginning from a big comedian that
changed you forever I watched something
happened um that affected me as
profoundly as you know Bill Burr uh
having said that or gim GA Jim gaffan
saying that to you I was opening for a
comic on the road and his big thing was
his wife and I hate my wife and I fresh
and I this and my wife and my wife and
my wife and whatever and he was divorced
and he had been divorced for years and
no one knew that and there would have
been no way to really corroborate it
back then not that I would have wanted
to but yeah I come off stage get him and
I remember uh right before he went on he
pulled a wedding ring out of his pocket
and
went has to wear hisa and had to put on
a wedding ring to go out to pretend to
be married and I remember just being
like that's hell yeah let me at least
just be the same person on stage and
offstage oh yeah because that looks like
hell I agree you know and I think
podcasting is tricky because it's like
whoever you are in the world I think is
who we should be in podcasting sometimes
I go I'm not being funny enough I'm
being boring I'm being this and I'm like
oh no that's not people aren't listening
to this in a room full of 3,000 people
drunk and like yeah that's right they
don't want that it's annoying no we joke
on you made it weird all the time we go
we stop trying to be funny years ago but
that's not entirely we do have really
really good laughs but like I'm so with
you but why can't we do both why can't
we be both why can't why can't we grow
and why can't we change and and the
audience grows and changes with you yes
and that's why I'm just like you know
it's funny we put my Batman videos we
made these Batman videos on the same
YouTube as my podcast I was like I think
we have to separate them which is fine
because I don't think people that are
looking for my Batman videos are looking
for like deep conversations with a rabbi
that's okay but I want to like find the
Right audience for everything so it's
always I believe it exists though I know
I know thousands of them exist but I'm
always trying I know there are more I
know there are more people that would be
like I like a good jizz joke and also I
want to be all of it yeah all of it but
it takes a certain it took I can't say
what it takes for other people it took
me a long time to get to a point where
I'm like I'm all of it I'm I love being
a little bit mean or a little bit or
very dirty and then I also love talking
about spirituality or Jesus or whoever
might be and uh accepting that I'm
accepted and accepting all of me I don't
think much is gained in pretending like
you don't have a shadow or you don't
have foibles or flaws or hate or Rage or
whatever it might be I think it's very
beautiful to put that on stage and laugh
at it I also think two things I also
think people are relieved to know that
we're okay yeah you know and I think
people are done with like oh I'm
watching these Comics that are really
funny but like are they going to die any
minute like I think they like seeing
that we are trying to stay healthy and
trying to um I think they root for us to
go like okay you can do all these things
but like I know you're okay at the end
of the day I get I mean I think you
really said something interesting in the
past there would be Comics like this and
that explode and I I think there's
something beautiful in evolutionary
about evolutionary about having someone
like Bill bur nobody's worried about
Bill bur's out eating a venison steak
and doing chin-ups yeah right right
right he's okay but it's like we're out
here trying to do this thing where a lot
of the people that came before us just
like died yeah and succumb to their
addictions and their egos and their
fears and their pain and their trauma
and we're trying to go like we're trying
to do the we're trying to like stay
alive here guys yeah and also Staying
Alive means processing that stuff they
paved the way for us to safely process
it they maybe even motivated us to
process it bill has a great line where
he's like you watch musicians exploding
he's like don't you guys watch Behind
the
Music and it's like yeah we do now yeah
and then also the last thing I'll say is
I think comedians it's our job to be
surprising that's what a joke is right
we lead you one way we surprise we
surprise you and I think that if the
onus is on us like maybe the most
surprising thing to do sometimes is to
be sincere and to be vulnerable yeah you
know and then people get to know us this
way and then they come see us they're
like holy and they're hilarious and
they'll talk about poop and they'll talk
about God
it's our job to just not be the same all
the time right it's funny though when
you do a podcast sometimes I go out and
I do my my new hour and there's no God
stuff in it that's why I'm trying to
write that Cheesecake Factory boss thing
uh and I'm like oh wow I bet a lot of
people not a lot but I bet some of them
were like he didn't even do the thing
that he does you know now I feel like
thank God in a way no I know I agree I
agree keep him guessing but at a certain
point I I am like oh I've made this Lane
for myself and I'd like to use it now
that I made it for you know other people
do it but I'm just saying I like to
you I'm in if you're starting a cold I'm
in what are we wearing what are we doing
we just go to World
Market they have good candy I love their
candy they have good side tables the
whole thing your baby you me in your
life right now Whitney I'm gon to be
gone I haven't seen you in years
probably won't see me for years it's
fine but right now this everything
everything you're reading everything
you're hearing it's all a trick
orchestrated by the only one there is
the only one thing that's happening to
tripwire you to fall back
into
love and then I turn into
codes this is I so in I'm telling you if
you start a Cole I'll however much it
costs I'm so in dude I'm so in maybe
your purse phone uh my I know why why
why is this door okay this is like the
new pocket protector now that my phone
has said look at your purse phone I know
exactly where it is cuz I never lose it
has my credit cards on the other side
okay everyone I know can never find
their phone got mine right here whatever
that's good every now and then you bend
over and it yes it hits you in the face
but that's also fine you got the
Chewbacca phone this is it why is this
dorky it's not I'm Normcore dude I'm
Normcore till I die Orlando tourist for
life is my
aesthetic dude I'm like about to be mom
I fanny packs I got I wait till I show
you my new vest that is like a tactical
vest with
pockets I just got a generator dude I'm
ready to be off the grid yeah you are I
love you I end these awkwardly don't
ride elephants Pete Holmes I'm not for
everyone LOL LOL LOL I hate your guts oh
I hate your
guts
[Music]
a